l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi visant à renforcer la
lutte contre les dérives sectaires la
procédure accélérée a été engagée sur ce
texte dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame Sabrina Agresti
roubach secrétaire d'État chargé de la
citoyenneté et de la
ville merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre madame la rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
12 juin 2001 la loi aboupicar était
votée créant le régime juridique de la
lutte contre les dérives sectaires elle
prévoit le délu d'abus de faiblesse lié
à un état de suggestion psychologique et
physique c'est un acquis important que
nous devons préserver près de 23 années
après cette loi l'État se doit désormais
d'adapter son organisation et sa réponse
pénale pour tenir compte des
transformations du phénomène des dérives
sectaires c'est un impératif auquel
personne ne peut se soustraire c'est la
raison de ma présence devant vous
aujourd'hui ainsi que celle de ma
collègue Agnès firmain lobodau ministre
délégué chargé de l'organisation
territoriale et des profession de santé
pour l'examen du projet de loi visant au
renforcement de la lutte contre les
dérives sectaires il y a donc la
nécessité d'adapter notre droit mais
également une détermination sans faille
du gouvernement à mener ce combat et à
venir en aide aux victimes des
mouvements sectaires c'est tout le sens
de la stratégie nationale pluriannuelle
de lutte contre les dérives sectaires
qui a été diffusé en novembre dernier à
l'issue d'une importante concertation
interministérielle cette stratégie
nationale compte 1è objectifs et 40
mesures opérationnelles parmi lesquelles
le projet de loi visant à renforcer la
lutte contre les dérives sectaires que
j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter
aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je souhaite le dire avec
clarté parce que c'est ma conviction
profonde l'État ne lutte pas contre les
croyances les opinions ou les religions
mais bien contre toutes les formes de
dérive sectaire la République garantit
la liberté de conscience nul ne doit
être inquiété pour ses opinions même
religieuse pourvu que leur manifestation
ne trouble pas l'ordre public établi par
la loi proclame l'article 10 de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen nous y sommes profondément
attachés en revanche l'État protège ses
citoyens contre ce fléau des dérives
sectaires qui représente une menace pour
notre cohésion sociale et dont les
pratiques dangereuses font des milliers
de victimes chaque année un fléo en
constante évolution laissez-moi vous
donner un exemple dans son dernier
rapport d'activité la
Mivilude alerte sur les solutions
miracles proposées par certains
pseudothérapeutes contre des pathologies
cancéreuses comme des des injections de
guif du jus de citron ou encore des
interruptions de soins de médecinees
conventionnell qui peuvent être
particulièrement dangereuses voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs ce à
quoi nos compatriotes parmi les plus
vulnérables peuvent être exposés
aujourd'hui face à ces charlatans dont
les méthodes d'embrigadement évoluent
sans cesse nous ne pouvons laisser les
victimes seules nous devons les protéger
si vous me le permettez j'aimerais vous
rappeler les grandes tendances qui
caractérise les dérives sectaires
aujourd'hui premièrement le phénomène
des dérives sectaires ne cesse de
prendre de l'ampleur depuis plusieurs
années les signalements à la milude ont
doublé depuis 2010 les difficultés
sociales et la crise sanitaire ont accru
les vulnérabilités de certains de nos
concitoyens et cela n'est certainement
que la partie émergée de l'iceberg
deuxièmement le phénomène s'est
transformé en tirant profit du
développement du numérique et des
réseaux sociaux à côté des groupes à
prétenions religieuses qui continuent de
sévir de plus en plus de petits groupes
et de gourous 2.0 féère de véritables
communautés d'adeptes en ligne
je veux également citer le développement
préoccupant de la sphère complotiste
dont les testes prospèrent sur la toile
la crise du covid-19 nous en a donné
l'illustration comme je viens de vous le
rappeler face à ce constat inquiétant le
gouvernement a mené une large
concertation afin de faire émerger des
propositions constructives je le disais
l'ensemble des parties prenantes ont été
réunis en mars dernier au ministère de
l'Intérieur et des outremères je tiens
d'ailleurs à remercier ma prédécesseur
madame la ministre Sonia baquè pour son
engagement dans cette cause qui je le
sais lui tenait tant à cœur la stratégie
nationale de lutte contre les dérifes
sectaires 2024-2027 est le fruit de ce
travail d'une ampleur inédite elle se
structure en trois axes un premier axe
dédié à la prévention des risques de
dérive sectairire un deuxème axe centré
sur un meilleur accompagnement de
proximité des victimes un trè axe
consacré au renforcement de l'arsenal
juridique et dont le projet de loi cons
situe la mesure
phare mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la rapporteur ce projet
de loi a pour objectif une réforme
majeure de notre dispositif juridique en
matière de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires elle aura des effets
importants tant sur la suppression des
auteurs tant sur la répression
excusez-moi des auteurs que sur
l'indemnisation et l'accompagnement des
victimes l'ambition du gouvernement est
notamment vous le savez de proposer la
création de deux nouveaux délits à
l'article 1er le fait même de placer ou
de maintenir une personne dans un état
de suggestion psychologique ou physique
à l'article 4 la provocation à l'abandon
ou à l'abstention de soins ou à
l'adoption de pratiqu dont il est
manifeste qu'elles exposent la personne
visée à un risque grave pour sa santé en
effet la santé est devenue un enjeu
majeur de la lutte contre les dérives
sectaires 25 % des signalements à la
Mivilude concern désormais la santé il
est essentiel d'y répondre notamment à
travers à travers cette mesure je
laisserai ma collègue gas firman leobudo
que je remercie chaleureusement pour sa
présence à mes côté aujourd'hui le soin
de vous parler à la suite de mon propos
de ce second délit proposé à travers un
amendement du Gouvernement visant la
réintroduction de l'article 4 par
ailleurs en cohérence avec la création
d'un nouveau délit d'assugjettissement
psychologique ou physique prévu à
l'article 1er du projet de loi du
gouvernement nous avons proposé qu'une
circonstan aggravant soit instauré pour
plusieurs crimes et délits commis dans
un environ sectaire pour être plus
précise il s'agit il s'agit donc d'actes
de torture de meurtrre de actes de
barbarie de violence ou encore
d'escroquerie il faut rappeler
qu'actuellement il n'existe pas de
circonstances aggravant en la matière
pénale liée à l'emprise sectaire cette
mesure doit doit donc permettre
d'adapter la réponse pénale au phénomène
sectairire en réprimant les agissements
à la hauteur de ces méthodes d'emprise
en complément nous souhaitons que
l'accompagnement des victimes soit forcé
par la possibilité de donner à plusieurs
associations spécialisées de se porter
partie civil une procédure d'agrément
par l'État sera mise en place pour
établir la liste des associations
autorisées à agir à la défense des
victimes une procédure de transmission
obligatoire des condamnations et des
décisions de contrôle judiciaire aux
ordres professionnels de santé et par
ailleurs proposé dans le projet de loi
elle permettra de faciliter la prise de
sanctions disciplinair à l'encontre des
PR praticien déviant enfin l'information
des acteurs judiciaires sur les dérives
sectaires sera améliorée par une
meilleure association des services de
l'État notamment la milude ces services
pourront être pourront être sollicités
par les parquets ou les juridictions
judiciaires pour leur fournir les
informations utiles basées sur leur
expertise qui seront de nature à les
éclairer je souhaite à présent vous
parler plus en détail des objectifs de
la création d'un nouveau délit
d'assujettissement psychologique ou
physique nous souhaitons agir en amont
de l'abus de faiblesse en sanctionnant
le fait même d'assujétir une personne
par des pressions graves ou réitérer ou
de techniques propres à altérer le
jugement déjà inscrite dans le droit
pénal ce nouveau délit permettra de
Sibler la mécanique néfaste de
l'embrigadement sectaire celle qui
détruit des personnalités coupe des
personnes de leur environnement familial
et ruine leur santé car cette mécanique
est bien la porte ouverte à tous les
abus nous poursuivons on là deux
objectifs premièrement remédier au cadre
juridique désormais insuffisant pour
appréhender les nouvelles formes de
dérive sectaire comme je l'ai déjà
évoqué la disproportion entre le faible
nombre de procédures judiciaires
engagées et la recrudiscence des
signalements àamivilude le montre bien
les statistiques judiciaires font état
d'une proportion importante de
classement sans suite pour infraction
insuffisamment caractérisé nous
constatons également un faible nombre de
condamnations soit 95 euh condamnation
sur 361 affaires instruit de 2017 à 2022
tout cela n'est pas satisfaisant
évidemment deuxièmement améliorer
l'indemnisation des victimes en
permettant de mieux reconnaître le
préjudice corporel qui qui résulte de
l'altération de la santé psychologique
ou mentale des personnes sous emprise
sectaire ass sujétir une personne ne
conduit pas forcément à un abus
frauduleux ou à des atteintes sexuelles
mais elle conduit fréquemment à une
altération grave de la santé physique et
surtout mentale et les séquelles peuvent
se manifester de multiples manières
syndrome post-traumatique syndrome
dépressif perte d'autonomie ou encore
isolement social ou encore affectif
extrême en l'état actuel du droit la
réparation par les tribunaux du
préjudice sur la santé est plus
qu'aléatoire cela n'est pas suffisant
pour les victimes elles doivent être
mieux protégé c'est l'ambition de cette
disposition prévue à l'article 1 du
projet de loi que plusieurs groupe
propose aujourd'hui de
réintroduire madame la rapporteur vous
avez souhaité enrichir le texte dans le
cadre de l'examen du projet de loi en
commission des lois de nouvelles
dispositions vous avez ainsi proposé de
renforcer la protection des mineurs et
de mieux lutter contre les dérives
sectaires dans le domaine du numérique
vous proposez également de consacrer
l'existence de la milude dans la loi
vous savez combien je suis attaché à
l'importance du travail parlementaire
j'étais moi-même commissaire au loi à
l'Assemblée nationale je salue ces
évolutions qui complètent utilement les
propositions du gouvernement et je me je
me réjouis qu'elles aillent dans le sens
de notre volonté commune de renforcer la
lutte contre les dérives sectaires et de
mieux protéger les victimes au-delà
j'aimerais également remercier toutes
celles et ceux qui s'engagent
publiquement pour cette noble cause je
pense bien sûr à l'ancien sénateur
Nicolas Abou et à l'ancienne député
Catherine Catherine Picard au auteur de
la loi de 2001 je pense aussi à Monsieur
George fenc ancien député ancien
président de l'ami vilude qui est un
acteur central de ce combat et qui l' a
été mais dont la voix continue de porter
beaucoup je remercie aussi l'ensemble
des associations spécialisées qui
agissent au quotidien pour venir en aide
aux victimes et à leur famillees leur
action est cruciale je vous le dis avec
gravité elles ont besoin de ce texte
pour aider les victimes toujours plus
nombreuses de se sortir de ces spirales
néfastes ce sujet nous rassemble et je
m'en félicite mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à travers ce projet de loi le
gouvernement entend renforcer grandement
la capacité de l'État à agir
efficacement contre les dérives
sectaires ce projet de loi marque une
étape importante du combat contre les
dérives sectairaires dans notre pays
nous devons répondre présent c'est un un
fléo qui nous concerne tous chacune et
chacun d'entre nous peut potentiellement
en être victime car nous avons toutes et
tous nos faiblesses nos fragilités
quelle que soit notre histoire
personnelle pour terminer mon propos
j'aimerais citer les sages paroles du
philosophe sec dans de la colère tous
les hommes ne sont pas vulnérable de la
même façon aussi faut-il connaître son
point faible pour le protéger davantage
je vous
remercie merci la parole est à présent à
Madame agès firmain lobudau ministre
délégué chargé de l'organisation
territoriale et des profession de
santé
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
Président de la Commission mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la menace que
représente les dérives thérapeutiques et
sectairees se diversifie notamment à la
faveur d'évolution profonde de notre
société et de son approche vis-à-vis du
soin mais aussi des difficultés
auxquelles fait face notre système de
santé ou encore du développement des
communications numériques en effet on
constate que les français ont
massivement adopté les pratiques dit non
conventionnelles en santé aussi
désignées sous le terme
PNCS 70 % d'entre eux ont une image
positive de ces pratiques selon un
sondage odoxa de mai dernier alors que
dans le même temps le nombre de
signalements et de demandes d'avis et la
Mivilude concernant les médecines
complémentaires et alternatives est
passé de 214 en 2015 à
892 en 2021 comme l'indique l'étude
d'impact du projet de loi c'est de ce
constat que que nous sommes partis
Sabrina gristirobach et moi-même pour
ériger un objectif que je pense partager
par un bon nombre d'entre vous il faut
mieux encadrer ces pratiques et
renforcer notre arsenal pour réprimer
les dérives les plus dangereuses pour
mieux encadrer ces pratiques et c'est
l'occasion pour moi de souligner que le
gouvernement s'est évidemment pas
cantonné à mobiliser uniquement des
leviers en matière de répression pénale
j'ai installé le 28 juin dernier un
comité d'appui à l'encadrement des
PNCS composé de tous les acteurs
institutionnels de la santé des ordres
de fédération d'établissements et ouvert
à la société civile avec la
participation d'associations de victimes
et d'universitaires ce comité travaille
depuis bientôt 6 mois et commence déjà à
produire ce qui servira demain comme
base à une meilleure information des
patients sur ces pratiques à une
meilleure évaluation et à une véritable
formation des
professionnels je réunissais une fois de
plus ce comité ce matin pour une session
de travail et les membres du comité ont
notamment établi tout un prramme de
travail pour 2024 et proposé du contenu
pour un outil d'information eu publi sur
les comportements déviants de certains
praticiens qui doivent les alerter et
les pousser au signalement mais au-delà
de ces travaux nous ne pouvons pas faire
l'économie d'un débat sur notre arsenal
pénal pour lutter contre les dérives les
plus dangereuses car oui trop souvent
des gourous continuent de porter des
discours qui constituent des risques
concrets pour celles et ceux qui les
écoutent tous les professionnels de
santé le disent ils sont trop nombreux à
s'être retrouvés impuissant face à des
patients ayant suivi les conseils
irresponsables de charlatan les
entraînant parfois jusqu'au pire c'est
cette logique qui a prévalu à
l'élaboration du présent projet de loi
et en particulier aux articles 4 et 5 du
texte
initial l'article 4 vise à réprimer dans
certains cas bien précis sur lesquels je
vais revenir la provocation à s'abstenir
de suivre un traitement
j'entends les critiques qui ont pu être
formulées mais laissez-moi redire mon
désaccord certains ont expliqué que cet
article n'était pas nécessaire au regard
des incriminations existantes notamment
du dél d'exercice illégal de la médecine
permettez-moi de rappeler que le dél
d'exercice illégal de la médecine ne
concerne que les cas de colloque
singulierers c'est-à-dire de relation
individualisé et que la jurisprudence
l'a qualifié de délit d'habitude
obligeant donc la R des faits pour être
caractérisé ainsi tous les discours
tenus dans le cadre d'un collectif
dirigé par un gourou ou diffusés en
ligne sont le plus souvent en dehors du
champ de cette incrimination de plus
certains médecins déviants échappent eux
aussi à cette qualification en raison de
leur situation régulière
d'exercice l'article 4 dans sa rédaction
initiale représentait donc une véritable
plusvalue ensuite nombreux sont ceux qui
qui essaient de présenter C article du
PGL comme attentatoire à la liberté
d'expression ou bien le résumant à une
condamnation de tout propos qui soit
éloignerait du soi-disant discours
officiel de la science je rappelle que
la rédaction proposée introduit quatre
critères cumulatifs nécessaires à la
caractérisation de l'incrimination
mentionnée au premier alinéa veillant
ainsi à ne pas porter atteinte à la
liberté d'expression de façon
disproportionné que les personnes visées
soient atteintes d'une pathologie que
l'abandon du traitement soit présenté
comme bénéfique pour la santé que les
conséquences pour la santé soient graves
et que le risque pour la santé soit
avéré au regard des connaissances
médicales la portée de cette
incrimination nouvelle est donc
circonscrite au discours présentant un
danger concret et celle-ci ne saurait
donc être considérée comme une
interdiction dans l'absolu de toute
critique envers des traitements
recommandés ou comme un obstacle à la
controverse scientifique en ce sens le
gouvernement présentera un amendement de
réintrodu ction de l'article 4 encouragé
dans sa démarche par l'ensemble des
ordres de professionnels de santé
l'article 5 lui vise à systématiser la
transmission d'informations aux ordres
par les parquets lorsqu'un professionnel
de santé est condamné ou placé sous
contrôle judiciaire pour des faits des
dérives sectaires l'objectif poursuivi
est notamment de faciliter les
procédures disciplinaires des ordres et
ce au bénéfice d'une meilleure
protection des patients alors que les
ordres ne sont souvent informés qu'à
l'issue de procédur en appel de mois
après au cours desquels la menace qui
pesait sur des patients s poursuivie
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis convaincu qu'il est nécessaire de
se doter de nouveaux outils en matière
de politique pénale pour faire face à
une menace d'un genre nouveau présentant
un danger concret pour les patients je
vous prie de croire que le gouvernement
a travaillé dans un esprit de
responsabilité à la rédaction de
dispositions exigeantes dans un souci de
ne pas porter atteinte au droits et
liberté fondamental de façon
disproportionnée au regard de l'objectif
de santé publique poursuivi
je sais que nous partageons cette
ambition alors travaillons ensemble dans
l'intérêt des patients je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est à présent notre collègue
lauian jossand rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues issu
des Assises organisées en mars dernier
le projet de loi visant à renforcer la
lutte contre les dérives sectairaires
poursuit une intention louable et qui
doit tous nous mobiliser lutter
efficacement contre les dérives
secteures dont la multiplication et la
diversité doivent nous interroger
collectivement ce projet de loi marque
un regain d'intérêt bienvenu sur la
question des dérives sectaires après des
années de relatif désengagements le
rapport de la commission d'enquête
sénatorial sur les dérives sectaires en
matière de santé à 10 ans 10 ans au
cours desqueles il n'a été suivi de
quasiment aucun effet au contraire cette
période a été celle d'une remise en
question de la Mivilude et de son
fonctionnement le projet de loi visant à
renforcer la lutte contre les dérives
secteures est présenté comme une réponse
au nouveau visagees des dérivve
sectairirees que l'arsenal pénal
existant peinerait à appréhender en
particulier dans le domaine de la santé
en effet deux évolutions majeures sont
décrites par tous les acteurs d'une part
le développement des moyens électronique
de communication et les réseaux sociaux
d'autre part les polémiques entourant
l'épidémie de covid-19 qui ont vu une
remise en cause des discours des
autorités publiques en matière de santé
mais également des données scientifiques
concernant les caractéristiques des
pathologies ainsi que l'efficacité et
les risques des traitements toutefois au
lieu de procéder à une évaluation
approfondi de l'arsenal pénal existant
et de s'interroger sur les causes de
l'émergence de nouvelles forces for de
dérive sectaire le gouvernement a
considéré que les Assises organisées en
mars appelaient une réponse législative
centrée non pas sur un renforcement des
moyens de la justice ou sur une
meilleure formation des professionnels
ni même sur une véritable politique de
prévention d'éducation et de
sensibilisation mais sur la création de
nouvelles dispositions répressives à
l'issue des auditions de l'ensemble des
acteurs impliqués dans cette lutte ma
conviction se trouve renforcée sur ce
point il convient avant tout d'appliquer
les lois existantes et de renforcer
leurs moyens budgétaires et humains pour
agir concrètement et pratiquement contre
les dérives sectaires en conséquence si
nous ne pouvons qu'approuver les
objectifs du projet de loi je vous
propose comme l'a fait la commission des
lois d'en aborder l'examen avec
pragmatisme et avec le souci de
faciliter des solutions opérationnelle
et inscrite dans la durée plutôt que de
nous contenter d'effets d'annonce de
solution de façade à des des problèmes
malheureusement trop réels juridiquement
le contenu du projet de loi ne paraît
pas à la hauteur des enjeux je regrette
en particulier que le gouvernement est
tenu à maintenir certaines dispositions
en dépit d'un avis négatif du Conseil
d'État soulevant le cas d'absence de
nécessité de légiférer ou les risques
constitutionnels pesant sur certaines
dispositions il me semble que la gravité
de ce sujet ainsi que les difficultés de
lutte contre des acteurs parfois très
organisés disposant d'importants moyens
doit nous appeler à la plus grande
responsabilité et avant tout à une
vigilance particulière le Sénat a
toujours fait preuve de constance depuis
la loi aboupicar sur ce point il n'est
ni envisageable de proposer de fausses
solutions aux victimes ni souhaitable de
légiférer sans que la nécessité en soit
avéré au risque de fragiliser tout
l'arsenal pénal existant il convient
également de veiller aux effets de bord
des règles présentées comme destinées à
lutter contre les dérives sectaires mais
qui auront en fait une portée générale
la commission des lois a en conséquence
préféré supprimer les articles 1er 2 et
4 du projet de loi plus précisément
l'article 1er vient doubler les
infractions existantes et risque
d'entraîner des confusions dommageables
dans l'application du droit pénal
notamment s'agissant de la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes et
contre les violences intra familial
l'article 2 en tire les conséquences en
créant en miroir la circonstance
aggravante de l'abus de vulnérabilité
une circonstance aggravante de mise sous
suggestion pour les infractions les plus
graves l'article 4 entend pour sa part
réprimer les provocations à l'abstention
ou à l'arrêt d'un traitement susceptible
de porter gravement atteinte à la santé
d'une personne que cette provocation ait
été ou non suivi desffits bien que
restreint dans sa portée depuis les CR
les critiques sévères adressé à sa
rédaction par le Conseil d'État il
demeure attentatoire aux liberté sans
garantie d'une grande efficacité contre
les sort du discours en faveur des
dérives sectaires nous aboutirions
paradoxalement à desservir la cause que
nous prétendons défendre si nous
laissons les tenants des dérives
sectaaires se draper dans le manteau des
libertés d'autres dispositions proposées
par le gouvernement nous semblent
toutefois aller dans le bon sens et nous
nous sommes attachés en commission des
lois à en renforcer la solidité
juridique je pense ainsi à l'article 3
du projet de loi qui tente à faciliter
la possibilité pour les associations de
se porter parti civil en substituant à
la nécessité d'une reconnaissance
d'utilité publique un nouveau mécanisme
d'agrément plus souple cela reconnaît le
rôle indispensable joué par les
associations de défense au côté de l'AM
vilude de la même manière l'article 5
renforce pour sa part l'information des
ordres professionnel au premierers rang
desquels l'ordre des médecins sur les
décisions judiciaires prises à
l'encontre de leur membres pour des
agissements impliquant des dérives
sectaaires en lien avec leur exercice
professionnel j'y voilà une avancée pour
faciliter les décisions ordinales dès
lors qu'une condamnation ou un contrôle
judiciaire en lien avec l'exercice
médical serait prononcé enfin l'article
6 prévoit pour sa part l'octroit à la
Mivilude du nouveau rôle d'amicus curiae
pour faciliter son intervention en tant
que service expert dans les procès enfin
la commission des lois a considéré que
l'occasion nous était don
de nous saisir de ce texte pour
permettre la mise en œuvre des
recommandations des rapports
parlementaires ayant fait date et
particulièrement du rapport de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale de 2013
nous avons tout d'abord doté la milude
d'un statut législatif ceci permettra
enfin d'inscrire cette mission dans la
durée et de conforter sa vocation
interministérielle qui est actuellement
très paradoxale pour un organisme
rattaché à un service du ministère de
l'Intérieur ce statut la protégera en
outre en la personne de son président
ainsi que les personnes qui lui font des
signalements contre les procédures
abusives en deuxième lieu je n'ai pu que
m'étonner de l'absence de disposition
dans le projet du gouvernement pour
réprimer les nouveaux modes opératoires
des auteurs d'infraction en lien avec
les dérives sectaires et ce malgré les
récentes évolutions du droit pénal en
matière de répression des infractions
commises en ligne en conséquence nous
avons introduit de nouvelles
dispositions tendant à renforcer la
répression des délites d'exercice
illégal de la médecine de pratiqu
commerciales trompeuses et d'abus de
faiblesse dès lors qu'il serait commis
en ligne ou au moyen de support
numérique ou électronique en troisème
lieu j'ai attaché un soin particulier à
la prise en compte de la situation
spécifique des mineurs victimes de
dérives sectaires en prévoyant que le
délai de prescription ne court qu'à
partir de leur majorité et en renforçant
les les sanctions applicables au fait de
placer un enfant dans une situation
d'isolement
social je souhaite remercier sur ce
point Nathalie de lâre avec qui j'ai
travaillé sur ce sujet tristement
d'actualité enfin il me semble que
certains amendements déposés par nos
collègues de touban pourrai utilement
compléter la copie sénatoriale du projet
de loi je pense en particulier aux
amendements de nos collègues bonau hbert
et Berté qui traitent de l'exercice
illégal de la pharmacie et de la
biologie en ligne mais également aux
amendements de notre collègue gu pardon
Benard roche sur le maillage territorial
des acteurs de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires j'émettrai en conséquence un
avis favorable à ces amendements pour
conclure il me semble que nous aurions
nous aurons pardon alors pu faire œuvre
utile sans donner l'illusion de créer ce
qui existe déjà donc en évitant le
risque de faire moins bien et d'ajouter
à la confusion des normes mais en
revanche en portant à leur terme le
fruit de travaux parlementaires réfléchi
et transpartisan je propose donc
d'adopter ce texte largement complété
par la commission des lois et expurgé de
ses principales fragilités juridiques je
vous
remercie merci Madame la rapporteur dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à présent à notre collègue
Jean-Baptiste blanc pour le groupe les
républicains pour 7
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres madame la rapporteur et
mes chers collègues l'actualité vient
illustrer la la pertinence de nos
travaux un groupe sectaire exploitant
des femmes sur des bases de pratiques
tantriques et l'enlèvement d'un enfant
caché dans un groupe nomade deux
structures transnationales qui ont
échappé au radar durant de nombreuses
années dans l'un et l'autre cas ces
groupements instrumentaliseent la
liberté au détriment de leurs membres
rappelant que les libertés ont d'abord
été pensées pour l'individu la loi de
2001 a déjà souligné que de teles
mouvement porte atteinte aux droits de
l'homme et aux libertés fondamentales
l'individu qui pour la République doit
rester un citoyen souverain doit être
protégé faut-il rappeler ici avec
l'accord d'air qu'entre le faible et le
fort entre le pauvre et le riche c'est
la liberté qui opprime et la loi qui
libère nous espérions un projet de loi
honnêtement plus ambitieux les Assises
Nationales de la lutte contre les
dérives secteurs en mars dernier annoncé
une feuille de route pour les 10 ans à
venir elles avaient été précédées par de
nombreux rapports de nos assemblées sur
le volet financier sur celui des mineurs
et particulièrement ceux conduits sur la
santé par la commission d'enquête
présidée par mon collègue du beaucluse
sénateur à un Milon dont je ne trouve
pas écho dans le projet présenté j'ai
l'impression que la feuille de route
s'est réduite à la taille d'un conféti
même si je ne pard pas de vu qu'il reste
encore 9 ans pour accomplir le chemin
cette déception est particulièrement
marquée par le choix restrictif du
gouvernement de se concentrer sur la
réponse pénale faut-il lier cette
réponse à la décision gouvernementale
prise il y a 4 ans de rattacher la
mibilude au ministère de l'Intérieur je
le pense et souhaiterait que le
gouvernement prenne conscience de ce
tropisme réducteur et redonne la milud
l'interministérialité et l'indépendance
est nécessaire je fais mienne la
proposition de notre commission de
donner un statut législatif à la
Mivilude le renforcement de la mission
en terme de personnel de moyens
financiers comme l'a rapporté notre
rapporteur précisément est plus que
jamais nécessaire pour permettre une
prévention efficace face à la menace
secteur nationale et internationale avec
un rôle prédominant des réseaux sociaux
des outils informatiques dont
l'intelligence artificielle et les
gourou 2.0 qui opère de manière souvent
conspirationniste au lieu de renforcer
la mut pour aider les les victimes le
gouvernement abandonne l'accompagnement
à la société civile qui bien qu'engagé
n'a pas nécessairement la compétence
professionnelle requise je me dois de
souligner ici la nécessité d'une
législation spécifique contre les
dérives secteaires malgré l'existence
d'un arsenal législatif général cette
entienne d'une législation suffisante
avait d'ailleurs été avancée lors de
l'élaboration de la loi en 2021 la
répété aujourd'hui ne sert à rien et le
volet pénal doit être amélioré car la
loi de 2001 après une vingtaine d'années
d'application timide à montrer ses
limites il est urgent ainsi d'attribuer
un code spécifique dès l'ouverture du
dossier pénal pour informer la mut des
affaires ou une dérive secteur est liée
à une infraction dite ordinaire
l'abandon de l'article 1er qui proposait
parce que problématique dans sa
rédaction et qui propose de créer une
infraction autonome d'abus frauduleux de
la situation de faiblesse de personnes
placées en état de suggestion
reviendrait à viidé de s'apporter le
projet de défense des personnes mise en
état de suggestion l'article 223 152
dans sa rédaction souvent mal comprise
resterait alors difficile à appliquer et
les victimes pourraient en pâtir il
faudra donc revenir sur ce sujet de
toute évidence pour comprendre cette
difficulté d'application il convient de
faire un bref historique de la genèse de
l'article 223 15 2 que je viens
d'évoquer réprimant l'abus frauduleux de
l'état de faiblesse et de rappeler qu'il
vise plusieurs catégories de personnes
déclarées particulièrement vulnérabl que
sont le mineur la personne âgée la
personne atteinte d'une maladie d'une
déficience physique ou psychique ou la
femme enceinte la loi de 2001 voté à
l'unanimité a élargi la protection des
personnes vulnérables au-delà des biens
ajoutant la catégorie de ceux en état de
suggestion psychologique ou ou physique
l'alinéa 2 de l'article 223 152 dispose
que si l'infraction est commise par le
dirigeant d'un groupement créant la
suggestion les peines sont aggravées
introduisant surtout l'idée que la
suggestion peut-être créée chacun sait
tout cela la difficulté à distinguer les
personnes vulnérables par définition de
celle dont la vulnérabilité est
provoquée par les pressions du dirigeant
du groupe abusif a été mise en évidence
par les différentes décisions de justice
rendues depuis 2001 certaines décisions
exigent à tort de démontrer une
vulnérabilité préexistante alors que le
texte indique clairement que cet état
peut-être créé cette confusion découle
de la manière dont la 6e catégorie de
personnes vulnérables a été ajouté et
dont le législateur avait bien voulu
protéger les biens le déplacement de
l'ancien article du code pénal du titre
protection des biens à celui de la
protection des personnes a entraîné une
confusion cette confusion occultant
l'intention de mettre en sujestion
malgré le rappel de la loi du 2001 sur
le l'atteinte aux droits de l'homme et
aux libertés fondamentales par le
groupement en question l'article premier
qui a donc été supprimé
venait préciser justement en tout cas
apporter un début de précision sur la
situation de la personne assujettie en
érigeant un délit autonome à son égard
ce qui était réclamé par les praticiens
amener à défendre ce type particulier de
de victimes donc répondez à une attente
mais encore une fois la rédaction
problématique peut-être à tibe en fait à
ce stade malheureusement un rendez-vous
manqué par ailleurs je voudrais évoquer
les dossiers d'emprise sectaire qui
implique la dimension régionale
mentionnée dans l'article 223 152
c'està-dire que la cellule d'assistance
et d'intervention en matière de dérive
sectaire donc les décrit décrit cette
dimension comme une forme archaïque de
de gouvernement où le manipulateur
cumule les trois pouvoirs normatif
exécutif et judiciire et cela crée une
toute puissance qui légitime la
soumission de de l'adepte masquant cette
coeriss cette dimension groupale évite
la confusion avec les conflits intra
conjugaux cette seule réflexion sur la
dimension de gouvernance interne au
groupes de nature sectaire montre que
l'article 1er du projet tel qu'il était
présenté aurait pu être retravaillé pour
être accepté quelque part car il touche
au fondement du paradigme démocratique
je voudrais vous mettre en en garde
contre l'édulcoration de la spécificité
de l'emprise groupale dans le texte en
discussion la Cour de cassation a
qualifié très justement le groupe
sectaire d'institution ce qui est ce qu'
l' est réellement aux yeux de l'adepte à
sujéti si les apports de la Commission à
ce projet vont dans le bon sens je crois
que l'instauration de l'infraction de
mise en état de suggestion ou
d'assuggétissement même si elle n'est
qu'une des facettes multiples de la
question constitue un outil
indispensable ce projet de loi mesames
les ministres est donc à ce stade un
rendez-vous manqué puisqu'il a été
précipité qui n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux tels qu'on vous les décrit
nécessaire d'adapter les outils de lutte
contre les dirait que c'est des secteurs
qui touchent la santé l'alimentation le
développement personnel le numérique ou
encore les mineurs l'histoire d'Alex
jeune Anglais retrouvé 6 ans après
desance soulligne cette nécessité le
Sénat a travaillé avec sérieux et amendé
le texte de 16 amendements et sans doute
d'autres lors de cette séance je salue
le travail de notre rapporteur à ce
titre mais ce sujet des dérives secteur
méritait mieux qu'une réaction
précipitée pour protéger les quelques
500000 adeptes de mouvement sectaur et
les 8000 enfants et lever dans un
contexte sectaire selon la miibéude mais
aussi et surtout sensibiliser protéger
tous les autres qui ont qui sont
approchés chaque jour je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
préssent à notre collègue Vincent louau
pour le groupe les indépendants pour 5
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministres madames les ministres madame
la rapporteur mes chers collègues
renforçant dynamique déjà à l'œuvre la
crise sanitaire a considérablement accru
la part du numérique dans nos vies les
réseaux sociaux en ont massivement
profité de 54 millions d'utilisateurs en
2018 TikTok est passé à plus de
689 millions en juillet 2020 les
algorithmes et les bulles de filtre
fracturent notre nos sociétés et mettent
en péril nos institutions sur ces
plateformes les individus ne sont sont
de plus en plus seuls et la
désinformation circule de plus en plus
vite alors qu'il devait devrait devait
nous reler les réseaux sociaux nous
isolent des individus sont isolés sont
des individus plus vulnérables le
phénomène des dérives sectaires n'est
pas nouveau mais il s'adapte et tire
avantage des évolution technologique
l'arrestation de plusieurs responsables
d'une secte de yoga svissant en Europe
nous rappelle la réalité des menaces qui
pèse sur les plus faible de nos
concitoyens traite de personnes
séquestration viol ou encore abus de
faiblesse nous devons faire davantage
pour les protéger le texte que nous
propose le gouvernement entend renforcer
la répression des mouvements qui
exploitent la vulnérabilité des
personnes la Commission a déploré à
juste titre que la mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires ne
dispose pas de suffisamment de moyens
d'autant plus qu'elle doit répondre à un
nombre de signalements en forte
augmentation comme la Commission a pu
elle-même s'en convaincre la Commission
a cherché à enrichir le texte elle l'a
fait avec la création de circonstan
aggravante relative à
l'utilisation pour la commission de
certaines infractions de moyens de
communication en ligne nous comprenons
que l'objectif poursuivi par la
rapporteur a été de ne pas ajouter de
nouvelles dispositions à notre droit
mais bien de mieux faire appliquer celle
qui existe déjà nous remarquons
cependant que le texte n'a pas été
réduit en commission mais augmenté y
compris pour pour transcrire dans la loi
des dispositions qui figurent déjà dans
un décret nous craignons que ces mesures
soi soient insuffisantes
la Commission a dans le même temps
supprimé l'article 1er qui crée le délit
de placement ou de maintient dans un
état de suggestion psychologique ou
physique puni 3 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 375000 €
d'amende tout comme les associations
d'aide aux victimes nous regrettons
cette suppression ce nouveau délit
aurait en effet contribué à mieux
protéger nos concitoyens en donnant à
nos forces de l'ordre et nos magistrats
les moyens de poursuivre et de condamner
des actes qui échappent encore à la
justice l'article 4 visé quant à lui à
mieux imander les dérives relatives aux
médecines alternatives la milude indique
faire face à une hausse très
significative des signalements les
concernants la pandémie a libéré
semble-t-il la créativité des
détracteurs de la science même parfois
au sein de cette Assemblée la Commission
a fait le choix de supprimer l'article 4
nous voulons croire que ce choix a été
motivé par les réserves exprimées par le
Conseil d'État plutôt que par les
centaines de mails envoyés par les les
princi principau intéressés reste qu'il
faudra bien trouver un moyen de lutter
contre ces dérives en matière de santé
l'article 5 constitue à cet égard une
avancée nous nous félicitons qu'il est
échappé à la suppression il nous semble
important que les ordres professionnels
concernés soient informer des dérives de
leurs membres et puissent prendre des
mesures qui s'imposent à leur égard dans
un monde de plus en plus numérique nous
redoutons que les dérives sectairaires
ne continuent leur progression la la
question des moyens financiers consacrés
à la lutte contre ces mouvements est
assurément incontournable nous devons
renforcer ce dont la min
Mivilude don dispose la Mivilude la
prévention est elle aussi une étape
importante dans la lutte contre les
dérives sectaires nous devons faire
davantage en la matière si nous voulons
éviter que nos concitoyens vulnérable
n'en devienneent victime il faudra
cependant nécessairement adapter notre
arsenal répressif
si nous voulons que la justice puisse
agir en amont avant que des drames ne se
produisent notre groupe soutient les
objectifs poursuivis par le texte du
Gouvernement merci chers collègues la
parole est à présent à notre collègue
Dominique verien pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui les dérives
sectaires se sont multipliées en partie
à cause des réseaux sociaux qui
permettent à ces discours de toucher le
plus grand nombre cette menace a aussi
grandement évolué au groupes à
prétention religieuses viennent
désormais s'ajouter une multitude
d'individus qui investissent plus
particulièrement les champs de la santé
de l'alimentation et du bien-être en
2021 4020 signalements ont été
enregistrés un
record ce chiffre est en augmentation
constante depuis plusieurs années plus
33 % entre 2020 et 2021 + 86 % depuis
2015 devons-nous lutter ou considérer
qu'après tout chacun est libre de penser
et de se soigner comme il
l'entend pour ma part je considère que
notre mission est de nous protéger
d'indiv qui sous couvert de
bienveillance mettent des gens sous
contrôle pour faire d'eux leurs choses
et au passage s'acaparer leur bien car
ne nous y trompons pas derrière
l'ouverture des chakras la transcendance
interplanétaire ou le traitement de la
calviciie à coup de jus betterave se
cache une réalité bien plus matérielle
cette fois sonnante et trébuchante et
bien souvent ces gourous recherche
autant la soumission psychique que celle
des comptes en banque les Inconnus le is
bien lorsqu'ils font dire à ce quiipie
le grand gourou tout bien que tu détiens
est un souci qui te retient il nous faut
donc lutter contre ces individus bien
sûr on pourra m'opposer qu'il existe
déjà des sanctions pénales pour les
pratiques commerciales trompeuse pour
l'exercice illégal de la médecine pour
le harcèlement moral ou l'abus de
faiblesse c'est vrai mais est-ce
suffisant au regard des chiffres et des
rapports probablement non après avoir
entendu la kémade assurément non en
effet nous sommes face à une menace
particulièrement difficile à appréhender
protéiforme discrète qui joue souvent
avec les limites de la légalité en
s'abritant derrière la liberté de
conscience pour isoler petit à petit ses
victimes et avec des victimes qui n'ont
pas conscience de l'être il est donc de
notre responsabilité de doter l'État
mais aussi nos magistrats nos policiers
nos gendarmes des outils juridiques les
plus efficaces ce qui n'est pas simple
car le texte du Gouvernement était
apparemment trop large en particulier
sur les articles 1 et 4 pourtant il me
semble qu'une réécriture plus fine
aurait été préférable à une simple
suppression des articles en cause
l'enjeu le mérite il semblerait que la
nouvelle rédaction ne convienne pas non
plus espérons que la navette permett de
trouver la bonne rédaction pour pointer
au plus juste les dérives que nous
combattons par contre je tiens à saluer
le travail de la rapporteur visant à
consacrer les pouvoirs et le rôle de la
mivilut dans la lutte contre les dérives
sectaires les acteurs de la lutte contre
les dérives sectaires étaient très
inquiets lorsque la Mivilude a changé de
ministère de tutelle plusieurs l'ont dit
avant moi les remous qui s'en suivirent
avec le préfet Gravel ne firent
qu'accentuer cette
inquiétude espérons donc que ce texte
lui donne un nouveau souffle et qu'elle
puisse conduire des actions de
prévention ambitieuse qui font
aujourd'hui défaut à la réponse publique
notre groupe regrette également que le
texte du Gouvernement n'aborde pas la
question des financement mais ma
collègue Nathalie Goulet aura l'occasion
de vous en reparler en fin de compte
plus que louable l'intention du
gouvernement est nécessaire ces menaces
évoluent particulièrement vite et autant
le dire franchement nous avons déjà du
retard en ce sens j'espère que nous
aurons l'occasion d'enrichir le texte au
cours de nos débats et au cours de la
navette mais en attendant le groupe
centriste ce
texte merci la parole est à présent à
notre collègue GUID bénaroche pour le
groupe écologie solidarité territoire
pour 5
minutes madame la ministre mesdames les
ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues l'actualité récente avec
l'affaire de ce jeune Britannique de 17
ans nous a rappelé à la réalité des
dérivpes sectaires enprise psychologique
destruction de la cellule familiale
isolement social exploitation financière
parfois sexuelle il s'agit bien plus que
d'une pensée ou d'un mode de vie à la
marge de la société pourtant le danger
lié au dérivve sectire semble un peu
pris en peu pris en considération par
les pouvoirs publics à tel point qu'en
2020 la disparition de la Mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires
Mivilude a même pu être évoqué certes il
y a bien eu des Assises nationales au
début de l'année mais comme l'a montré
notre commission sans aucune des
recommandations des rapports
parlementaires transpartisan qui ont été
conduits au cours des dernières années
seulle une ébrochche de réflexion sur de
nouvelles dispositions pénales est
apparu au travers de ce
texte le texte proposé par le
gouvernement manquait de mesures sur le
numérique et était pourvu d'un certain
nombre de risque d'inconstitutionnalité
relevé par le Conseil d'État dans son
avis publié le 17 novembre 2023 nous
aurons l'occasion de présenter des
pistes d'amélioration basées sur des
travaux parlementaires notamment sur la
formation des professionnels du troit
dans nos amendements nous assistons ces
dernières années une augmentation des
phénomènes sectaires qui prennent
désormais de multiples formes plus
seulement vocation religieusees et
spirituelles ils investissent les champ
de la santé de l'alimentation du
bien-être du développement personnel du
coaching ou de la formation en 2021 le
nombre de saisis de la M vilude abandi
de 33 % pour atteindre 4020
sollicitations soit 86 % en plus depuis
2015 un quart des signalements à la
mvilude tourne autour du sujet de la
santé et du bien-être le texte qui est
sorti de notre commission a bien pris la
mesure de l'effet amplificateur qu'on eu
les réseaux sociaux ces dernières années
et a donc introduit une nouvelle
circonstance aggravante si les
infractions sont commises au travers de
ces réseaux si l'aspect d'asce
financière est presque toujours au cœur
de ces pratiques délétaires les
conséquences psychiques et physiques
sont aussi importantes notre commission
a tout autant pris la mesure des dangers
pour les mineurs et a ainsi modifié les
règles de délai de press inscription en
cas d'abus de faiblesse nous avons donc
pu en commission conférer à la Milu d'un
réel statut législatif pour confronter
son R et ses missions face au phénomène
des dérives sectaires dont le nombre
comme les formes ne fut qu'augmenter
nous saluons à ce titre la prise en cte
du nouvel aspect numérique de ces
phénomènes nous le savons tous le climat
de défiance a perfusé tous les domaines
et les discours antiscientifiques on
peut être amplifié notamment par l'usage
des réseaux sociaux depuis l'épidémie du
covid-19 et les dérives dans ces
discours arrivent vite ventant des
traitements non étudiés non validés les
situations d'incertitude médicale ou
personnels sont propices à la diffusion
de soi-disant réponses aussi simple que
miraculeuse il existe un risque pour la
santé publique des personnes vulnérables
peuvent se laisser convaincre par
quelques margoulin de suivre des
pratiques de sohait délivré par des non
professionnels et susceptible d'être
dangereuse pour leur santé le
gouvernement doit développer des
politiques sur la prévention afin de
réellement lutter contre l'émergence de
groupes isolés dédiés à la santé au
bien-être et sujet à de nombreuses
dérives et
charlatanisme au-delà donc du rôle
conforté de la Mivilude la place des
associations est tout aussi mise en
avant très au fait des méthodes de
certains mouvements il reste elle reste
un des piliers de la lutte contre les
dérives sectaires leur accompagnement
des victimes et de leurs proches est une
des clés de la meilleure préhension
judiciaire des faits délictueux voire
criminels
aussi la reconnaissance qui leur est
apportée est plus que juste car comme
nous avons pu le dire l'arsenal
législatif pour éprimer les agissements
de ces communautés existent déjà c'est
bien sa connaissance et sa mise en œuvre
qu'il convient d'améliorer à ce titre
nous portons des amendements issus des
travaux des sénateurs mard et Millon si
leur mission se concentrait sur les
dérives thérapeutiques et les dérives
sectaires leur préoccupations plein de
bonens et de retour d'expérience
mériteraient un soutien bien plus
important ils ressortaient de leurs
travaux que les magistrats comme la
Protection Maternelle et Infantile
pourraient bénéficier du soutien de
l'État dans leur formation afin de
connaître au mieux les mécanismes en jeu
et de permettre des détections chez les
enfants entre autres le rapport de 2013
préconisit le déploiement d'une campagne
d'information sur le sujet nous n'avons
bien sûr pas pu soutenir une telle
mesure pour cause de recevabilité
financière mais nous invitons fortement
le gouvernement à s'engager en ce sens
il apparaissait aussi dans ce rapport
libéralité des préfectures dans la mise
en œuvre de cellules dérivé dérives
sectaire c'est donc un texte très
largement insuffisant composé plutôt de
petites mesures pour reconnaître dans
notre arsenal pénal l'existence de ces
phénomènes sectair mais sans agir sur
les causes des phénomènes je salue donc
les travaux de l'autre commission qui
ont fortement modifié le projet initial
complétant les dispositifs proposés par
des mesures plus opérationnelles pour
lutter plus efficacement contre le Flo
secctter d'autes aussi d'autres groupes
solid ité territoire sera attentif au S
réservé aux améliorations de bon sens
qu'il portera sur le texte et s'il garde
l'équilibre donné par la commission
votera en faveur de ce texte merci chers
collègues la parole est à présent à
notre collègue au président Pierre
ououia pour 5 minutes pour le groupe
crceek monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres madame la rapporteur chers
collègues
le principal mérite du texte proposé par
le gouvernement est d'attirer notre
attention sur la recrudesence des
dérives sectaires elle sont en partie
nourri par la montée de l'irrationalisme
la contestation de la science la perte
de légitimité des institutions politique
et scientifique la propagation par les
réseaux dis sociaux de récits
complotistes et l'illusion que chacun
pourrait se constituer sa vérité à
partir d'informations glané sans méthode
sans médiation et sans
vérification c'est tout à fait à raison
que le gouvernement considère que ces
processus de sugestion des individus
sont particulièrement nocifs quand ils
touchent à leur santé néanmoins les
dispositions législatives proposées par
le gouvernement pour protéger la santé
de nos concitoyens ne concerne que le
code pénal et le code de procédure
pénale alors qu'il aurait fallu
s'interroger sur leur relation avec le
code de la santé surtout quand elles
sont relatives à l'exer
illégale de la médecine par ailleurs
madame la ministre ce n'est pas le
Conseil d'État qui écrit la loi mais il
est tout à fait raisonnable d'écouter le
Conseil d'État pour écrire la loi en
l'occurrence vous auriez dû entendre ces
critiques sévères à l'encontre notamment
de la rédaction de l'article 4 de votre
projet qui porterait atteinte selon lui
au principe constitutionnel de la
liberté d'expression des libertés
académiques et de la liberté fondamental
d'accepter ou de refuser un traitement
médical spécifique garanti par la
Convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme toujours à propos de
cet article 4 et parce qu'il serait
funeste qu'il soit réintroduit dans sa
rédaction actuelle à l'Assemblée
nationale j'observe qu'il instaure un
délit de publicité en faveur de pratique
à finalité thérapeutique récusé par la
science médicale mais qu'il ne précise
pas si les professionnels de la médecine
sont aussi concernés en d'autres termes
comment cette disposition
s'articule-t-elle avec la loi du 20
décembre
1988 relative à la protection des
personnes qui se prêtent à des
recherches biomédicales dit loi Hurier
il faut défendre la liberté de la
recherche la possibilité pour les
savants de soumettre à une scène
critique leurs résultat et la nécessité
de nouvelles pratiques thérapeutiques
mais ces travaux ne peuvent s'affranchir
des règles déontologiques et éthiques
propres à la médecine comme le rappeler
le professeur Alain ficher président de
l'Académie des sciences dans une tribune
du 28 mai dernier il est impérieux que
la démonstration des effets
thérapeutiques des médicaments respecte
les droits et la sécurité des personnes
qui participent à la recherche je
regrette vivement que les graves
méconduites scientifiques commises
durant la pandémie de covid n'ai pas été
plus rapidement et plus sévèrement
sanctionné la liberté de la recherche
impose un strict respect de l'intégrité
scientifique avec la rapporteur de la
commission des lois je déplore la
précipitation avec laquelle ce projet a
été élaboré puis soumis à notre examen
il eut été de bonnes politiques qu'il
profita des travaux importants réalisés
par le Parlement et notamment du rapport
rendu par le sénateur Jacques mard en
avril
2013 je comprends donc l'impuissance de
la Commission à corriger un texte aussi
peu abouti et sa décision d'en supprimer
quatre articles le texte ainsi remanié
par la commission apporte quelques
ajouts utiles dans le code pénal mais
son principal apport réside dans la
reconnaissance législative de la Mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires Laam
vilude qui vont ainsi sa mission
renforcée alors que son autonomie avait
pu être menacé par le passé cette
institutionnalisation de la milude avait
été préconisé par George fenec dans son
rapport remis en 2008 elle doit
maintenant être accompagné d'un d'un
renforcement de ses moyens et de son
budget pour qu'elle puisse jouer un rôle
efficace contre les dérive sectaire
aujourd'hui dans l'état du texte de la
commission nous voterons favorablement à
cette
proposition merci chers collègue merci
la parole est à présent à notre collègue
Nathalie de lâre pour le du
Rassemblement démocratique social et
européen pour 5
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame la rapporteur chers collègues en
décembre 2000 l'émission d'investigation
envoyée spécial présenta un document
édifiant et inédit à l'époque sur la
secte emmenée par Claude vorillon
surnommé
raë après les drames du Temple du Soleil
le grand public découvrait comment
s'installerit l'emprise d'un gourou
aussi fantasque que dangereux sur des
adeptes fragilisés et bientôt dépouillés
humainement comme financièrement
aujourd'hui chacun le sait les dérives
sectaires ne se caractérisent plus
seulement par ces groupes mimant des
croyances pseudoeligieuses le phénomène
s emparé d'Internet des réseaux sociaux
et plus généralement de tous les outils
que le numérique propose les gourous en
ligne fleurisse caché derrière des
pseudos et des discours aux allures de
sciences alternatives mais surtout aux
conséquences toujours aussi dramatiques
pour ceux qui adhère à leur parole le
groupe RDSE se préoccupe depuis déjà
longtemps des dérives sectaires nous
avions déclenché en 2012 la création
d'une commission d'enquête sur
l'influence des mouvements à caractère
sectaire dans le domaine de la santé
dont le rapporteur était le sénateur
Jacques mzard ce rapport fut rendu
l'année suivante et continue de faire
preuve d'une grande per
à l'image de certaines de ces
recommandations reprises par notre
commission des lois nous nous en
réjouissons mais qu'un rapport datant
d'une dizaine d'années soit encore si
actuel sonne comme un avertissement
préoccupant j'y vois le signe d'une
décennie au cours de laquelle nous avons
trop peu agi en la matière vous l'aurez
donc compris notre groupe a accueilli
avec enthousiasme ce projet de loi mais
nous déplorons qu'il nous soit présenté
en fin de session à la suite du marathon
Budet budgétaire nous privons ainsi du
temps suffisant à engager un travail de
fond conséquent à la mesure de la
problématique c'est d'ailleurs une
difficulté que vous semblez avoir
également rencontré mesdames les
ministres avec le Conseil d'État qui
l'indique dans son avis ce texte dont
des vies humaines dépendent a été
préparé dans un délai contraint et force
de constater dans une rédaction
approximative le sujet méritait mieux il
n'en reste pas moins que le texte
comportait des mesures fortes
je pense aux articles 1 et 2 qui
intégrit un dispositif répressif
protégeant les victimes en état de
sujection psychologique ou physique si
cette situation aboutissait à une
dégradation grave de leur santé s'il
vous
plaît je pense ensuite à l'article 4 où
vous nous proposiez de façon maladroite
toutefois de réprimer la provocation à
l'abandon ou à l'abstention de soins ou
à l'adoption de pratiques
pseudothérapeutiqu lorsque des actions
présentées comme bénéfiques exposer les
personnes concernées à des risques d'une
particulière gravité pour leur santé je
regrette que pour ces trois articles
notre commission a fait le choix de les
supprimer alors même cèg s'il vous plaît
si vous pouviez laisser parler madame de
Lat ce serait très bien merci merci
monsieur le Président je regrette donc
que pour ces trois articles notre
Commission ait fait le choix de les
supprimer alors même que le Conseil
d'État avait certes souligné leurs
imperfections rédactionnelles mais
affirm le caractère incontestable de la
légitimité de l'objectif poursuivi je
vois cette suppression comme un pas de
côté que notre groupe regrette mais je
comprend aussi le manque de temps qui a
étreint la Commission et je voudrais
saluer le travail de la rapporteur
d'autant plus pour un premier rapport
bravo avec modestie en plus de vous
proposer le rétablissement des articles
1er et 2e j'ai cherché à réécrire
l'article 4 en lui ajoutant des
gardesfous supplémentaires le
gouvernement a également poser un
amendement de rétablissement de
l'article dans lequel les contours de
l'infraction semblent mieux dessinés
quand bien même il demeureent des
imperfections la navette parlementaire
pourrait porter ses fruits en tout cas
nous l'espérons vivement pour le reste
les apports de la commission nous
satisfont je pense en particulier à
l'article 2 B issu d'un amendement que
j'ai pu défendre au côté de la
rapporteur et qui devrait permettre
l'allongement du délai de prescription
lorsque l'abus de faiblesse est commis
sur une victime
mineur je pense également à
l'inscription au niveau législatif du
statut de la mivilut qui suit une
recommandation du rapport mesard il est
impératif que cette instance soit
protégée et renforcée statutairement
nous avions d'ailleurs été alerté à ce
sujet lors de nos travaux en 2020 avec
Jacqueline stage brigot durant la
commission d'enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste et les moyens
de la combattre que je présidais et nous
en avions fait notre première
proposition ces nouveaux AJS sont donc
les bienvenus de sorte que si aucune des
anciennes dispositions n'était rétablies
nous voterions malgré tout le texte mais
non sans regret mesdames les ministres
au regard des enjeux je vous remercie
merci chers
collègues la parole est à présent à
notre collègue Olivier Beitz suite à
quoi je suspendrai la
séance
monsieur le le Président Monsieur le
mesdames les les ministres monsieur le
Président de la Commission madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues alors je
vais essayer de de faire l'intervention
la plus brève possible sur le sujet
parce que je sens qu' qu'un autre débat
est attendu dans cet hémicycle mais
néanmoins il s'agit d'un d'un débat
important d'un sujet important en effet
les dérivfes sectaires concernent chaque
année plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
victimes en France et deux décennies
après l'adoption de la loi picar force
de constater que notre dispositif
législatif ne correspond plus aux enjeux
actuels notamment en raison de
l'évolution de la menace qu'il s'agisse
des technologies qu'il s'agisse
maintenant des sujets portés sur la
médecine nous avons besoin d'adapter
notre droit c'était c'est la vocation de
ce texte présenté par le gouvernement je
ne peux que regretter que en commission
nous ayons voté la Commission est votée
euh la suppression des articles
notamment des articles 1 et 4 qui
permettaient de mieux cerner au niveau
pénal la la les les agissements que nous
souhaitons don auquels nous souhaitons
mettre fin il s'agit de prendre plus en
amont les dérives sectaires par rapport
à ce qui est fait actuellement avec
l'état de de faiblesse et permettre
ainsi de répondre à la demande d'un
texte supplémentaire qui est présenté à
la fois par les policiers spécialisés
dans le domaine par les magistrats mais
également par le monde associatif je
crois mes chers collègues que nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir tout ça à
l'occasion du débat sur nos amendements
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci Monsieur
Vitz je vais à présent suspendre la
séance quelques
instants y